[Music]
good morning bachelor nation thank you
so much for tuning in to e t--'s roses
and roses a live I am Lauren Zima and I
am here with wills yes oh you're putting
that smile on but we will alert
everybody we lost wills on bachelor in
paradise last night on ABC how you
feeling not great not great all right
well guys wills is the sweetest he's got
the biggest heart and he's a little sad
today so we need your questions and
comments for him of course let us know
anything that you want to know from
wills I'll get it here on the iPad and
we are going to dive right in so wills
you're not feeling great tell me why no
let's be a long road you know ever since
I stepped out that limo at the mansion
all the way into getting kicked out you
know on the beach and now it's kind of
like everything's kind of setting in and
I feel like America's finally caught up
to where I currently am and it's a
little disheartening here do you mean
that you have been feeling upset and now
you know finally everybody sees yeah I
mean I I knew how I felt and now
everyone else is catching up to that
feeling so it's just kind of like a real
wave of everything coming in and I just
kind of deal with it all over again so
we're here we're dealing with it
what was so frustrating for you about
being sent home from paradise I just
personally the reason I went to paradise
was you know kind of you know I was kind
of heartbroken I wasn't kind of hard I
was heartbroken after Becca sent me home
and you know I had the opportunity to go
to paradise and the reason I wanted to
go to paradise was to have the
opportunity to find my person and I'd
felt like I didn't really get that
opportunity I was only there for a few
days and I was pretty shocked just like
the rest of everyone else watching I was
pretty shocked that means it over the
first week so it was tough let's talk
about Bibiana giving colton that rose
because colton looked a little shot I
got to be honest there was a moment when
Viviana kind of looked off camera and I
thought was she looking at and what's
she connecting with right now in this
moment I don't know it felt I'm gonna
throw it out there it felt like maybe
for the sake of the show we needed
Colton to stick around I don't know what
are your thoughts on it I mean I don't
know I don't really know what's going
through her
I wish I did that would help me with my
process a little bit but did you expect
Viviana to give you that rose yeah
absolutely hundred one hundred and
twenty five percent why she told me that
multiple times that it was my rose and
she wanted me to stay around we had a
pretty platonic friendship early on but
we were both kind of with the agreement
that we wanted to keep each other around
to see if there was someone else out
there for us and that didn't happen I
don't really know why that happened she
didn't she was never the biggest Colton
fan ever since he came on to the beach
so that's even more shocking it would
have been it wouldn't have been a shock
game and say like Angela or something or
someone gave him her rose because they
kind of had interactions I feel like the
only interactions baby I didn't : hat or
Bibiana kind of telling Colton he needs
to get off the pot with TIA so it was
just interesting that she gave a rose to
it I was shocked too Angela give her
rose to venmo Jonna yeah me too I don't
I don't really remember them having any
real real interactions as well so that
was a shock to you when Viviana gave
Colton the Rose instead of you
absolutely what went through your head
in that moment host I don't really know
like everything kind of just went numb
for a second I kind of I wasn't really
as distraught as with Becca a situation
because that was a huge shock but this
time it's kind of sad to say but I was
almost like I wasn't surprised as much
as I expected to get a rose and the
second I didn't get it it was just like
I'm kind of used to getting hurt at this
point so I don't really care that much
like I it wasn't I didn't feel
heartbroken but I felt betrayed so would
you consider Bibiana your friend now how
are you guys now I'm cordial with
everyone I don't really hold resentment
towards anyone I just want people to be
upfront with me and honest with me and
if you say something to me back it up
and that's all I asked for I never
really considered her to be romantically
inclined towards me but then again she
did say things that she didn't back up
when the time came for it and that's
kind of distasteful a little bit so why
do you think she gave Colton the Rose I
don't know I really I don't know they
asked me that as soon as I got in the
car I honestly don't know I I don't
really think there's a reason for it I
don't know like ever since
Golding out on the beach she was talking
she was putting him in a bad light she
didn't really want him to be there I
think most of the girls didn't really
want him to be there and for him to for
her to give him her rose I don't really
understand maybe we'll see later on
maybe she has a interest in him or
something that to me that's the only
like valid reason or excuse for her to
get roses like she's been kind of been
waiting in the wings
Tiye chose Chris so now maybe Bibiana
wants to pursue cold that's the only
valid reason I talk to her at all yeah I
talked to her quite a few times and
that's nothing I mean that's not the
reason she gave me but I mean she I mean
if you talked to her since taping a
Paradise ended and everything like yes
and don't you ask her like on a tax turf
like what happened I like to keep my
temper in check
and I don't once it happens to me your
actions speak a lot louder than words
you can tell me whatever you want like
she did on the beach but her actions
spoke differently so to me it's like
once you didn't give me a rose that's
all I need to know I don't need any more
explanation that okay well that is heavy
all right well tantrum is saying wills
for bachelor on YouTube Michelle wants
to know wills in the limo I think maybe
in the van or the SUV whatever when
you're leaving paradise you expressed
interest in some of the women well who
are you interested in going into
paradise I'm not gonna lie
Kindle I was very into Kindle we didn't
really have the best conversations and
her and Joe kind of latched on kind of
immediately so that kind of closed the
door Astrid was another one I went for
and I actually did actually go after her
but I think it's a little too little too
late as her and Kevin over already
vibing and me and Viviana were on a good
speed so I thought I was at least gonna
have at least another week to kind of
figure it out and see who else would
come through well Kendall she did get so
deep with a grocery store Joe so quickly
but then she made how it was somebody
else last night yeah she made over the
John I believe yes that really threw me
for a loop I was shocked by that I'm
like you have grocery store Joe this guy
who has gotten this fandom around him
from being only night one guy and he's
into you and you're into him here having
these weird conversations and then you
make out with John I was surprised I
don't know that's another thing and
those a lot of people were making
more than more than one person which is
completely in there right but I kind of
got the vibe from some of the ladies
there that I was friends owning a lot of
them but in actuality I just wanted to
get to know them all before I don't I
don't want to just hop to each and every
girl like that's not my style my style
is yeah pick one and I'll go on in and I
tried to do that and it failed well who
was the one you're picking I picked
ashtray before the rose ceremony but it
was a little too too little too late her
and Kevin were already kind of already
took off a little bit so I should have I
should have jumped on that the first day
when I was a really interesting there
when I'm shy well it's weird cause like
you said I mean I do think in Paradise
the whole vibe is you know
bachelor/bachelorette it's skews me
you're going for this one person and
paradise the vibe asyou need to go for
everybody and going for everybody means
like making out with everybody which is
crazy do you wish that you hadn't gone
on paradise no like I said to you before
I believe everything I do is gonna lead
me to her I don't you know I don't be
the woman you should have yeah the one
the woman I will end up with I don't
regret it at all I just wish I had more
time to make connection to the people so
we did see Colton tearing up last night
crying over Tia and over Becca I'm
making a little guest appearance and we
also saw Colton telling Tia that he
wanted to explore his options how did
you feel watching Colton's
words and actions last night what were
your reactions I'll call the death but
I'm just honestly gonna say I'm
completely over it the whole Colton
entire storyline was part of my
storyline a Bachelorette it's also part
of my storyline of paradise um I'm
getting emotional now because I don't
feel well today guys and you're gonna
hear the truth I just felt like a lot of
emphasis was putting on Colton Colton
call them Colton's happiness and I felt
like I really got push back and the same
thing on paradise like I felt like he's
had an opportunity with Tia outside of
Bachelorette he's got an opportunity
with her at the end of a jeweler that he
had an opportunity with him at paradise
and he still can't make up his mind like
just make up your mind it's not that
hard you have a beautiful woman who
wants you that's all I want
and I didn't even get the opportunity
and I was gone the first week so that's
just frustrating me I don't I love cold
and death but I'm tired of talking about
Colton everyone's talking about how
everyone's talking about how oh he's
just coming from heartbreak because he
bounced back on this who was the last
person to go home right before Colton me
no one asked about that at all it's like
my happiness or has he gotten over
anything like that's just not even
considered like I'm I'm actually I
didn't know Becker came but I'm kind of
glad I love what I did because the Becca
came when I did like I don't know how it
would respond because I wouldn't have
wanted to see someone that I had just
told it I was falling in love with now
come back or I'm trying to figure my
life situation out and she's absolutely
engaged in prance around the beach like
that's not something I wouldn't wanted
to see either so I completely feel in
that vein at the same time I keep
getting asked about Colton's happiness
should he would be with TIA should he
not be what yeah it's like you to me
that's a good problem to have like you
have someone who's adamant about you I
want anyone to be adamant about me so
I'm just tired of talking about going
deal personally I'm well what is making
you tear up because there's a difference
between being like annoyed and then you
know it's just frustrating I want people
to also understand that there's more
than one person who has gone through
heartbreak there's more than one person
who wants to find someone there's more
than one person who wants to be happy
you know I feel like me and Colton's
kind of transitioned from Bachelorette
to paradise they're very very similar
like almost less than a week removed
almost the exact same and at people were
head over heels about Colton can he feel
better oh my god Becca he's uh what did
I hear today he's about to have a
breakdown all this stuff it's like I I
completely understand that I feel the
same way
I just don't show my emotions as much I
internalized you've seen me in both car
rides and I've looked just upset and not
crying I doesn't mean I'm not hurting
you no I'm saying just be good tears are
not the only indicator of hurt so it's
just I just want people to know that as
well like I also have been going through
it as well and it's just frustrating
where do you stand on being past things
with Becca are you that I you know I
want to win on paradise if I didn't feel
like I had gotten over her but like I
said if I did see her on the beach
prancing around with an engagement ring
around all these single people trying to
figure the life out
I just feel like it's not necessarily
disrespectful but it's just a little bit
of a slap in the face and kind of like
putting your face in the mud and I just
I don't I don't think I would have liked
that if I was there it sounds like
you're feeling frustrated because you
make a lot of effort to like hold your
emotions in and be mature and rise above
but then you feel like you as a person
get dashed to the side because you're
not having those bigger reactions yeah
absolutely but I'm just I don't
I'm not going to borrow my my eyes out
because I feel like people need to see
that like my emotions are my emotion
however I'm feeling the moment I'm
feeling in the moment you know I I feel
like I was you know I was hurt with
Becca I was hurt
kind of with Astrid and I'm kind of with
Astrid and with Viviana and it's that's
three girls over in the span of a month
two months and it's just now I can
finally just be open with it and it's
just I'm tired I'm being completely
honest and it's just I've been putting
myself my heart out there telling people
all about my backstory in my life all
these personal things that I don't
really tell people and it's for what
well that has to make you look at going
on on these shows though because it
isn't so you go on TV and you open up
about yourself and you tell so much
about yourself I mean would you have
some people go on paradise again or on
winter games would you do another show I
don't know as of right now I I have no
idea I'm just really I'm more concerned
with how I am and how I feel currently
as opposed to finding so we're gonna go
I tried it and it didn't work so right
now I'm just kind of I'm kind of just in
you know a pause phase right now and
just really worrying about taking care
of myself so what do you think you need
to do to take care of yourself to feel
better for this enjoy enjoy life like
everything so serious like I just want
to you know meet people and be friends
with me
one not necessarily friendzone people
but just you know have conversations and
then if things blossom from nothing
Boston from that but I don't want it to
be so intense and I feel like I have to
get engaged and all these things like I
just I just want to enjoy myself for a
little while you know what would mean to
happen for you and Bibiana to be okay
and are you and Colton okay okay I'm
going okay I don't have problems anyone
but I feel like but I feel like that's
such a guarded thing to say to be like I
don't have problems with anybody you
clearly and I'm not saying you don't
like I don't have a problem with me I
just
I'm gonna be honest and tell you how I
feel and I felt like you know baby all I
said one thing and then she didn't act
on that and now that hurt me you know
I'm saying I also the process I'm gonna
Colton where I was heartbroken and then
you went back into paradise and I was
disappointed by that and I just want
people to know that I don't have
anything it gets Colton Colton feels bad
just like I felt bad you know I'm saying
we're in the same boat I just want to be
vocal about it because if I'm not vocal
about how I feel and how I perceive
things then it's not gonna be heard well
there's been a lot of discussion about
Colton's motivation because you know
first he dated TIA
then he goes on Bachelorette then he
goes on paradise and in Paradise says
he's there to explore options and figure
himself out so you know I mean I've met
Colton he's very lovely but people have
wondered is he trying to be the bachelor
is he on that train of trying to become
the bachelor something else what do you
think I don't know I don't know I mean
if you came to Paradise to explore other
options I believe I think Chris I can't
remember I think it was Chris or Jordan
in the neck I believe you said if you're
here to explore your other options you
would have took someone else on a date
and which is pretty true I mean if you
already dated to you why don't you try
it something someone else out you know
and go out with I don't know asteroid or
anyone else you know so that's I mean I
kind of understood that and just to me
it's just like you want to explore other
options but then you keep going to
talking to you and then tea is telling
you one thing just tell it like let's
yeah I don't want to talk to you here
I'm gonna explore my options like it was
never just a firm statement it was just
always kind of you know you know
teetering around it and like walking on
eggshells and for me it's just like I'm
the kind of person like
it's I'm gonna confirm something and
then be done with it I'm not gonna keep
you know keep talking about it they were
talking about it before the bachelor
during the match saw it
now paradise it's not that hard either
you guys want to pursue something it
also seems like you know they really
hadn't spent that much time together I
don't think so it was really weekend
right dragged out it was interesting to
me to see because I do think that you
guys from Becca's season you're all
pretty good friends and I know Colton is
your friend but then it felt like you
could see the tension these past two
episodes of paradise it seemed like you
guys were as much as Colton as your
friend frustrated with how he was I just
like as a person I just feel like we're
kind of getting tired of talking about
the same thing I'll never get well and
in Paradise you're just sitting on that
beach you can do to talk about this a
couple more questions coming in for you
Dana deny says you stayed true to
yourself we are proud of you and Maria
says yes wills I'm sorry you're not
feeling good but we love you yes yes
Sarah wants to know if you think that
Becca and Garrett will last
yes I think they will last I think they
hit it off very well from the beginning
and it seems like they were still vibing
great and I feel like their relationship
is very effortless I don't feel like
they have to try to are it to be with
one another and I think they generally
want to make each other happy so yes
okay it's of course we're seeing Becca
and Garrett they're happy they can be
out in public so they're together a lot
now but who is Garrett close with from
you guys this season like who's close
friends with Garrett I would say myself
Jason what about Blake where does Blake
because Blake was such a I was I mean
Garrett and Blake we're close but I mean
after I mean I left I don't know like
you know I'm saying that I'd have to be
difficult I don't see like Garen like
having coffee and talking about like
what about you guys in Blake do people
came up with Blake Blake was nice too
but yeah but for those guys those are
two of the most popular guys in the
house everyone loved them and it showed
okay I love it well yes we love this
love coming in for wills because he
needs it right now you guys so keep
sending him these nice and messages so
last night we had
episode two of paradise tonight is
another episode on ABC
what do you know or what can you tease
for us about how the drama Wilkinson
you from here to be honest I have no
clue okay what's going on okay I don't
even really know if I want to watch it
you're not gonna watch it I probably
will yeah I mean I want to see I want to
see how my friends like you know react
to interact and you know make the
connections but it's just every every
moment I see from now on it's gonna be a
what-if for me so it's gonna be a
bittersweet to watch but I think is
there anybody who you felt like
underwent a transformation in paradise
sometimes people change or get a chance
at redemption I feel like Chris is
teetering on that level I feel like he
has the chance but he's got to be
careful okay he did find himself again
in the middle of the drama with Colton
again but we'll see I feel like he I
feel like he went to Paradise really to
try to you know reinvent himself and I
wish him the best yeah and he owns that
I meant lol - he was I went off the
Jordan I'm liking Jordan on paradise I
am I like Jordan commenting on things
Jordan do you think his intentions are
true I think so I think so definitely I
mean he kind of saw like he didn't have
to take an Elise on that little I like
the little one he's like you know how
does it feel to have a date without you
without even having a date card I
thought that was cute I was like okay
you're drunk
little things yeah I took a couple notes
from one story not taking social notes
that was really cute like he didn't have
to do that and he did it so I think you
know I think he's really there for
reasons all right well wills from here I
mean it's obviously been an emotional
last 24 hours for you what do you want
people to know about your journey about
what they maybe didn't know before what
he want them to take away I don't regret
anything I did I had a great time I
loved it I enjoyed it I'm still on my
hunt for her and I'm not gonna stop you
know even though I have days like this
tomorrow will be better and you know I
just want you guys to know that and you
know rock with me awesome everybody
follow wills on social media send him
your love and of course that we are
going to be your every Tuesday morning
recapping bachelor in paradise
there's another new episode tonight on
ABC it's every Monday and Tuesday and
then on Wednesday mornings we will be
putting up a new episode of roses and
roses a the taped version where you know
I go a little crazier thank you guys so
much for watching and we really really
appreciate you bachelor nation have a
everybody by
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]